I think sometimes the scariest scenes
are the easiest to shoot we knew exactly
what we were doing
um because we had the blueprint on on
the movie right next to us as we watched
it can you talk a little bit about the
shower scene in Psycho it's totally the
same it's totally the same
[Music]
so whereas they might have had a lot of
more improv going on and what's going to
be scariest here we knew exactly what
was scariest and as an you know respect
to Hitchcock we did it exactly the same
way and also did the things that he
couldn't do there's a shot in the
original Psycho where she's dead at the
end and he started on her eye and
technically they couldn't do the entire
shot the way that he wanted to so we
were able to because of technology today
so it was an expansion of that scene I
hope in in a very honorable way to him
the way that Gus thought he would like
it done now if I get this right he says
I get to do the sequel
thank you Mr Bates Norman Bates
we kind of tease about showing both
films side by side and and how trippy
that would be for people but hopefully
the people our fans will enjoy the the
new colorized version and the new colors
that are put into it and for those who
haven't seen it I hope we give it to a
new generation I mean it's a brilliant
brilliant film and there's some people
who still don't see black and white
don't you go out with friends
well a boy's best friend is his mother I
saw it as more of a fun challenge you
know it's almost like free ride like wow
we're going to be slammed fantastic this
is more freedom than anything I when you
already know that people are going to be
hesitant that really makes you go then I
guess I can do anything but I really
think that people are going to enjoy it
we all go though man so
haven't you
yes
sometimes just one time can be enough
did you talk to Janet Lee at all about
the part no although I did want to get
in touch with her our first day of
shooting which was kind of magical was
her birthday and so Gus sent her flowers
and she sent back a lovely note saying
you know good luck and and I wish you
all the best